[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette fois en
question son absence fois en question
pour laquelle j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui tu imites
chapelle et christophe hendrix qui me
bonjour bonjour
christophe bonjour bonjour donc kimi est
en ce moment en thèse sur le dinosaure
masson ce qu'on dit luce à l'université
de victoria strand en afrique du sud et
christophe hendrix nous via ii de
belgique et il a fait sa thèse sur les
dinosaures théropodes au portugal alors
aujourd'hui la grande question du jour
ça va être de discuter de ces fameuses
articles de cette fameuse controverse
sur le clad désarmante hausse et dida
want it hausse qaïda ça dépend comment
vous le prononcer donc ce club des
ornithologues calida qui rassemblerait
théropodes burn it is tient et qui du
coup mais très fort entre est par terre
le clad qui a été depuis très longtemps
dont l'existence a été depuis très
longtemps à nice mme des sceaux risque
rien donc ça va être une discussion qui
va être énormément basé sur la
phylogénie donc on va employer un
vocabulaire qui va être un peu
particulier notamment nous avons
beaucoup utilisé les termes monofil
éthique clad poliphile éthique par affi
l'éthique donc si vous avez besoin de
révision réviser avant d'écouter la
suite donc commençons d'abord par on va
commencer dans l'ordre chronologique de
la parution des articles donc on va
commencer par l'article qui a soulevé la
controverse donc baronne et al
2017 dans lequel une nouvelle analyse
phylogénétique des dinosaures a suggéré
a fortement suggéré qu en fait le clad
des sceaux risque rien qui rassemble
normalement théropodes et ce au repos de
mort n'était n'existait pas et qu'en
fait les théropodes étaient plus près
désormais titien que des soeurs open et
au milieu de tout ça il y avait les nra
zo rider qui se baladait donc les airs
et valoriser ces intrus cdc des
vestiaires qui viennent d'amérique du
sud c'est ça des gens de la zone
amérique du sud argentine ce sont des
carnivores qui ont été placés parmi les
théropodes puis parmi les sur les
soutiens bazzo et pas certains auteurs
les places même comme des dinosaures
donc qui ne compte ne serait pas placé
ni parmi les ornithischiens ni parmi les
souris scanner les dinosaures bazot mais
oui c'est vraiment un groupe représenté
par quelques membres et ça ça bouge
beaucoup dans la phylogénie des
dinosaures d'accord donc est ce qu'on
peut faire un petit rappel christophe
sueur sur l'historique de ces termes son
risque client qui se tient sur quoi se
basent et depuis quand depuis quand ça
existe oui parce que justement de
retracer l'histoire de la classification
des dinosaures ça va permettre le pense
à tes auditeurs de comprendre un peu
dans quoi dans quels cas si fication
situe donc en 1942 il ya richard owen
qui propose le
ternes dinosauria ont regroupé donc
trois genres méga loto russe qui est un
dinosaure carnivore iguanodon qui est un
dinosaure proche des dinosaures au bec
de canard et il y en a aujourd'hui un
dinosaure cuirassé et depuis cette
époque là entre 1842 et 1887 il y avait
trois classifications dinosaures qui
était proposée par trois paléontologues
très important la première c'est celle
qui a été proposée par edward bunker
coop en 1866 1867 où on avait des
groupes comme ornitho peau d'agneau
claude à sainte foy coda des choses qui
n'ont pas persister la deuxième
classification et je la présente parce
que on va en parler
par la suite z qui était proposée par
thomas henry pac cela qui est un
paléontologue britannique un ardent
défenseur de la thèse de darwin
d'ailleurs et en 1869 en 1801 70 propose
les groupes l'éclade méga l'autorité
pour comprendre et calorifique et l'iso
rider skelly d'autorité pour comprendre
ce qu'il y ait deux heures qui est un
dinosaure glacée et idoines aux
orchidées
on comprend le dinosaure herbivore
iguanodon et il comprend méga l'autorité
ce qu'est le 2e rider et higuain wanted
est dans un groupe qu'il nomme ornithos
calida en 1870 et la troisième une
classification c'est celle que tout le
monde suit c'est celle de moniales
othniel charme marche qui en 1100 entre
1878 et en 1884 propose les groupes que
tout le monde connaît normalement moins
ceux qui s'intéressent aux dinosaures
sauropodes les dix nageurs allende nous
allons que terreau paul et innéov
carnivore qui ont donné naissance aux
oiseaux et qui comprenait à cette époque
là mais caloz or les orbites à pauvres
qui comprennent donc iguanodon
ainsi que les dinosaures avec le canard
et stégosaure ya qui condamnait et qui
comprend donc les dinosaures courade
cuirassé comme stégosaure et en 1887
c'est là que harry govier si les quêtes
un paléontologue britannique du king's
collège de londres note que c'est 4
groupe de dinosaures ont la
particularité d'avoir des bassins très
différents c'est à dire que il constate
que les sauropodes et les théropodes ont
une anatomie du bassin qui similaires ou
le pubis et pointé vers l'avant alors
que chez les ornithologues délester 2 or
on a un public qui pointe vers l'arrière
on a toujours les trois haut layon
lézignan et le pubis mais c'est
l'orientation du public qui permet à
s'il est de proposer une victime ni au
niveau des dinosaures la première il
nomme le groupe or ni tisca qui signifie
à bassin d'oiseaux c'est celui où les
dinosaures ont un public qui pointe vers
l'arrière ça comprend à cette époque là
les stégosaures et les ornitho pauvres
qui sont des dinosaures exclusivement
herbivores et puis le deuxième groupe ce
sont les souris soutien ou le pubis
pointe vers l'avant et c'est un groupe
qui comprend les sauropodes et les
théropodes théropodes sont des
dinosaures quasi exclusivement de
majoritairement par des carnivores alors
que les sauropodes sont des dinosaures à
y voir où elle en est cette
classification a vraiment persister
jusqu'à nos jours pendant 130 années
cette dichotomie a été supportée par des
analyses cladistique alors qu'il
faudrait peut-être expliquer ce que sont
des années kalistick parce qu'on doit
parler à ces biens soient mais où cette
dichotomie entre sourds ischia et sur
les siens a toujours été retrouvés dans
toutes les analyses balistiques qui ont
été faites jusqu'à celle de barande de
cette année donc une analyse
claudie stx et juste pendant pendant
jusque dans les années 70 sont en gros
on faisait de la classification des
espèces un peu au pifomètre
et voilà cladistique pour faire simple
c'est juste qu'on a mis des matchs par
dessus histoire que le processus soit
répétable quantifie les observations en
série 2 0 et 2 1 et après on fait une
analyse mathématique la mairie
statistiques c'est juste une
formalisation de des observations dans
un contexte répétable et et j'ai envie
de dire avec un algorithme derrière qui
est aussi cet algorithme aussi permet de
répétabilité des observations du coup
puisqu'on parle d'un islamiste est bon
on peut parler de cette nouvelle analyse
statistique
et là je me tourne vers qui me disent
que puisque l'un des coauteurs paul
barrette je crois même que c'est le
seigneur aux torts de l'été voilà le
dernier auteur de la publication qui est
du coup l'auteur qui a chapeauté le
l'étude est donc paul barrette qui a
donc chapeauter le l'étude
debard honnête halles dont qui a remis
en question la mono fil idées sort
ischia est aussi l'un des superviseurs
de ta tests et ton nombre figurent
d'ailleurs dans les remerciements de cet
article vente eut tué je pense la plus à
même de nous parler de cet article
badaboum mois pour moi je travaille sur
les eurobonds ne manquent donc moi je
les aider avec les caractères tu suis je
seul le doublé des parents c'est cool
même ban a discuté pas mal sur légataire
et les spécimens mandat ici et j'ai
aussi j'ai fait scanner des artisiens
nous met ignorait complètement
évidemment que le résultat va être
il a bien gardé ça il va garder certains
moi même je crois des gars comme moïse
était tout ce qu'il n'était pas au
courant
alors il tombé dessus comme ça même à
une certaine manière donc tu as
participé la publication barmen et pour
ma licence de terrain pour prendre ça ok
t'es tu pourrais parler de ce que je
crois que ça pourrait intéresser les
diables que lille et comment fait-il
très sympa raging les vendanges lettres
et les films qu'on a été son terrain
première fois puis j'ai été visité haïti
plus dure et moi on a été un en
angleterre on a été voir et se dit
qu'ils aient tort d'en rendre le
résultat de barnetta est que la fin de
la phylogénétique ils ont trouvé montre
que les politiciens télé ce report
serait donc partageraient les sons qui
paie si la plus proche les
ornithischiens fait plus progestérone
paul qui le descend rapidement et donc
dans la réponse de la mairie talent qui
est sorti
pendant qu'ils étaient publiés l'attend
ils ont donc repris le second appel la
matrice de caractère de baronne état et
ils ont changé ils ont ils ont réalisé
qu'il y avait plusieurs problèmes dans
le codage des caractères que barnetta et
ils ont changé 2500 codage des
caractères et en faisant ça
quand il faut parler vrai de la matrice
originale c'est parce que c'est une
matrice qui est le nombre de caractères
le nombre de d'espèces qu'ils ont inclus
de danse c'est quelque chose d'unique ce
soft est la matrice originale à 457
caractère et 74 qui est ouais bah moi je
veux mon superviseur pour hazard
travaille sur les rites et robben
1000 caractères mais c'est quand même
c'est certainement la matrice de données
qui comprend le plus de caractère et le
plus d'action toutes les analyses cas
ici qui ont été faites sur les
dinosaures bazzo et sur les ancêtres des
dinosaures qu'on appelle les dinosaures
aux morts de parler ça aussi dit nous
aurons mort si les origines et la plus
grande par exemple c'est une matrice de
données qui a été proposé qu'à part
cabré en 2017 et qui comprenait 256
caractère côté parmi 43 taxe est donc là
ce que propose baran c'est certainement
l'analyse balistique la plus la plus
importante puisqu'elle comprend le plus
de caractère et le plus de taxes en plus
ya de caractères et plusieurs taxes ans
et plus on va dire que l'analyse est
robuste la principale pour se jeter par
j'ai pas vérifié mais je sais pas
les arbres coude crânien beaucoup de
vertèbres fattu dit le plus il ya de
caractère et mieux c'est j'ai beaucoup
de littérature là dessus qu'ils te
diront que c'est un droit déjà on peut
on peut commencer à justement on peut
commencer à discuter un petit peu de ce
point de vue là c'est ce que bigger is
better
est-ce que plus il y en a et mieux c'est
et pour le coup il ya une littérature
assez importante sur le fait que plus on
compte de caractère dans une analyse
cladistique et plus on accroît le mot
plagiat en fait donc on baisse la
résolution enfin proportionnellement au
nombre de caractères quand on augmente
le nombre de caractères on baisse la
résolution de l'analyse en fait mais
donc déjà ça ça peut être une première
critique qu'on peut porter à cet article
de baronne et on sait que oui c'est
probablement la matrice la plus grande
sur les sur les dinosaures et les
dinosaures au mof mais c'est c'est pas
forcément son point le plus fort je vois
que kimi hoche la tête
bah ya aussi le plus qui sont un
caractère lotus ont un triste d'avoir
des caractères sont pas trop ça c'est
vrai qu'il ya un problème
l'indépendance de caractère m'a dit d'y
aller bronzer caractère c'est important
parce que comme si on est con code clara
terre et qu'après on comme un deuxième
père à terre tu dépends du premier
cercle
finalement ça ne
donc une belle à part entière sur la
folie qu'est la phylogénie nous avons
donc ça veut dire qu'en gros si on voit
l'incident le codage delà de la matrice
on a un caractère est ce que le
dinosaure et carnivores oui ou non
et qu'après on a un caractère est ce que
les dents sont pointus oui ou non en
fait on on est en train de faire deux
fois la même chose exacte est on des
locaux et eric terrien duplique le
caractère et du coup ça ça fausse le
signal parce que du coup on donne plus
de poids un caractère que qu'un autre et
c'est comme ça qu'on peut finir par
exemple avec avec des cloud qui
ressortent pas d'habitude tout ça parce
que on a juste sur koné quelque chose
donc et ça te dit plus plus on à
caractère l'alpi sénatrice d'avoir le
caractère comme ceux qui ne sont pas
comprendre ce qui est bien mais ce que
je comprends tout à fait ce point de vue
je comprends la canton reproposer les
caractères doivent toujours évité
d'avoir taclé 7 septembre de caractère
par contre je suis pas d'accord avec
vous sur le nombre de caractères pour
moi puis à de caractère est plus une
analyse qui peut être vu ça je comprends
très bien le fait que quand on augmente
le nombre de caractères on peut
augmenter le moc l'asie mais si on
commence à sélecter sélectionné j'ai pas
dit mais le mot place des convergences
dans ses politiques
c'est le mot savant on utilise pour se
faire mousser quand on veut parler de ce
que je voulais dire en fait c'est que si
on veut limiter sa matrice de donner un
certain nombre de caractères ça veut
dire en fait que on va on va confier à
les choisir
donc c'est tout à fait subjectif moi je
pense en fait qu'il faut utiliser un
maximum de caractère indépendant lâché
d'accord avec vous au niveau de la
dépendance et caractère mais pour moi
plus on propose au caractère plus en les
codes plus justement on évite en fait
d'avoir thierry picking femmes qui
lisent d'avoir sélectionné certains
caractères ce qui est pour moi tout à
fait subjectif quoi ça c'est un des
défauts de l'analyse cladistique sais
que c'est pas un processus qui est fait
en aveugle sinon c'est déshabiller un
simple aveugle digne et encore moins un
double aveugle c'est à dire que c'est
voilà c'est vrai que s'il s'agit de
circulation complètement subjectif louer
et fives et enfin entendre si moi j'ai
rien d'impossible
je veux le codé ouais
christophe cristobal cruz est exactement
la somme exacte parce que beaucoup des
caractères des fois même quand on mesure
un spécimens fossiles on n'aura pas
exactement à l'inflation mesurée par
mois que ce soit précisé en métal et
énormément de chance d'avoir des
différences
exact mais alors dans ce cas on essaie
vraiment lorsqu'on propose de nouveaux
caractères de les avoir extrêmement
précis qu est d'éviter toute ambiguïté
s'adaptait vraiment les choses et ça
c'est quelque chose que j'ai entendu
dire je sais pas si c'est vrai que il ya
certains caractères qui sont un peu
ambigu dans mon amatrice de parents
et ça a été reprochée donc ça a été
reproché par langueur et ses collègues
même s'ils ont décidé de ne pas changer
les caractères ils ont une vraiment ils
ont ils ont décidé de se consacrer
uniquement au codage des caractères qui
semblerait que certains caractères soit
ambiguës peu claires et donc évidemment
sa fausse les résultats caractère peu
clair ça genre est ce que est ce que
telle structure est grosse ou pas voilà
c'est ça exactement en a seront opposés
aux yeux chacun sont chacun a son point
de vue si on reçoit une distinction très
précis sur base de ratios des choses et
les ratios si cette procession donne un
chiffre exact
ce crossover sa ci-après tu trouves 0.55
et c'est là que j'ai tort d'accord donc
tout ça ça va explique un peu le
scepticisme qui a eu envers l'article
original de baron et al après il ya des
gens qui ont
enfin je dis il ya des gens dont moi je
me suis dit que finalement une unir les
sauts ischia non unir les ordinateurs
des théropodes avec les arts need is
tient finalement ça faisait un peu de
sens ça avait du sens dans
particulièrement quand on regarde du
côté justement de la morphologie du
bassin laisse au risque a finalement ils
sont saurai ce cas ça veut dire passer
en reptiles mais du coup tous les
reptiles ou un bassin de reptiles ce qui
fait de ce caractère caractère primitif
et du coup ça veut dire que le groupe
des souris ce cas est principalement
fondée sur un caractère qui est plaisir
morphy qu'élus et les caractères plaisir
morphing font de très mauvais enfin ne
font pas de clad et donc font de très
mauvais indicateurs taxonomique appuyé
aux toiles je ne sais pas du tout est ce
que tu lis des informations sur
l'orientation des patients chez les
dinosaures et les ancêtres des
dinosaures sache aussi vraiment pas très
sincèrement je ne sais pas quel est le
caractère primitif ou pas je sais que le
titre d'exemple si c'est les dinosaures
au marché d'un moment un bassin saulx
risque donc d'abord donc du coup pour
moi ça me semblait assez logique que
finalement le ce groupe des souris ce
kia ne tiennent pas dans cette analyse
statistique puisque il était fondé sur
un caractère qui était un peu mais alors
et là je vous avouerai que j'ai pas
vraiment creuser mais c'est pas parce
que la distinction en éthiciens et sorry
sien est basé sur la morphologie du
passeur que cette dichotomique le fait
que les eaux risquaient nisy siens les
caractères qui les définissent donc
laisser ma peau ma fille concerne le
bassin c'est à dire que ça fluctue
complètement en a gardé le nom horny
titien et souris siens mais la manière
dont ces classes sont définies a
complètement changé je ne suis même pas
certain
le bassin ce que le vaccin est encore
utilisé comme un caractère un clip terra
note comique pour définir les souris
scanner les antilles siens attend qu'il
ya d'autres évidemment il y en a plein
plein d'autres je les connais pas par
coeur je connais la police n'a pas menti
pour les dinosaures mais pour les laisse
aux ischio jambiers titien jeu mais ça
change tellement en fait ça change au
niveau des années statistiques ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que tant qu'on
retrouve cette dichotomie entre souris
ce qui en est ici bien que ce soit sur
base du crâne de la forme des demandes
ou du post crânien et même de la forme
du bassin
ça n'a pas d'importance tant que c'est
ces deux classes sont retrouvés qu' il
ya des caractères anatomiques qui
puisque les définir parfait mais là ce
qui est très intéressant avec la l'étude
de parents c'est qu'il a trouvé quelque
chose qui n'avait jamais été trouvé
auparavant à part on était solide et à
lorient alors ça c'est intéressant de le
dire c'est que oxley avait inclus en
fait tous les différentes lettres de
dinosaures qui existait à cette époque
là que je regarde encore c'est donc les
médias leurs idées ils avaient compris
également donc c'était quoi encore les
icônes augmente idées et il avait
compris les je crois c'est quoi c'est
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que de
solides aux anges ouais c'est ça c'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est que parmi
les ornithos qui est leader il avait
compris aussi des espèces ils sont
connus pour être des sauropodes
il avait compris ce qui autorise il
avait compris tes cils aux angles c'est
user 7
ce rapport à certains c'est le genre
c'est aussi un sauropode mort par balle
je crois que notre homme qui vit et est
donc voilà en italie da à cette époque
là en 1870 comprenait déjà aussi des
décès au repos des corps dans ce
département c'est globalement le même
mot que le mode in other way est
exactement ce havrais est tombé dans la
housse était intéressant en outre ces
bidasses c'est que ça au niveau niveau
de la plume de l'évolution des plumes ça
avait l'air aussi d'avoir de tenir au
mieux que le scénario où les théropodes
son groupe frère de ce report ouais ça
je peux en parler parce que j'ai je suis
en train de justement de faire une étude
sur les pigments elle est restée
commentaire chez les théropodes les
théropodes sont connus maintenant pour
être les ancêtres les oiseaux donc que
l'on voit dans leur évolution vraiment
l'évolution
une évolution de la plume avec au départ
des protoplumes qui sont en fait des
filaments élémentaires puis des plumes
un peu plus complexe symétrique puis des
plumes asymétrique mais on a retrouvé
aussi c'est finalement cette élémentaire
chez désormais titien donc ça veut dire
que ce serait très intéressant ce serait
logique d'avoir les artistes qui
approche des théropodes puisque les deux
possèdent des filaments tégument terre
les sortes de poils même s'il ne s'agit
pas des poules des mammifères et ça on
les retrouve pas chez les sauropodes qui
évite on a pas du tout de jamais on n'en
n'ont en effet parce que les européens
ne sont connus que par des restes de pau
à ica on n'a pas de restes de tégument
film en terre ce qui est intéressant il
ya deux choses à noter parce qu'en effet
on pourrait penser à rui en effet on a
des ambitions qui est donc les indécis
siens maso qui ont des filaments
élémentaire les théropodes aussi mais
c'était pas le cas justement tout l'été
repos de base eau qui sont connues par
des restes de pau fossilisés il faut
savoir de dire que c'est extrêmement
rare très difficile de trouver des
restes fossilisés et bien tous les
théropodes les plus primitifs n'ont que
des écailles on n'a jamais trouvé de
filaments main c'est le christ c'est le
fais ici on n'a pas ça on a chez
carnotaurus qui est un avis des
autorités même si c'est un ami du jury d
un cératosaure très belle très dérivés
c'est un groupe de dix hommes
relativement base mais on a également
des empreintes de pas alors évidemment
trouver des restes de pour le niveau d
pas mais en tout cas on sait que les
pieds étaient cachés les théropodes la
deuxième chose il faut savoir aussi
c'est que on n'a pas de préservation de
on n'a pas d'emprunt de poche les
sauropodes sauropodomorphes bazin on en
a qu'on n'a pas tous les restes de pau
n'ont été trouvés que chez des
sauropodes c'est à dire des ce
retournement relativement dérivés donc
voilà le les critères de de la plume d
protoplumes qui se présentent et chedid
en doute ici un péché des théropodes
elle elle n'est quand même pas cohérente
et on a retrouvé aussi il faut le noter
des restes de nos fils aimant
élémentaire chez les ptérosaures qui
sont donc proches des dinosaures met
donc il sait qu'ils sont qui sont des
reptiles donc ça veut dire qu'elle est
possible que les filaments élémentaires
soit treize ans chez des ancêtres des
dinosaures et ont disparu chez d euros
pour le mords et je suis pas apprécié
les opticiens chez les théropodes
l'offre donc là dans le papier de
barnetta le groupe en octobre ce qui
vide est supportée soutenu par 15
caractère 15 caractères sur 453 des
caractères qu'ils ont dans leur analyse
soutient le risque évident parce que tu
parlais justement des caractères qui
soutiennent d'accord donc est-ce que ça
ce sont des caractères qui sont qui ont
l'air d'être comment pourrait-on dire
académie qui on me dit robuste ou est
robuste par vous même donc on dirait que
la plupart c'est idk la terre corse
crânien des caractères du squelette
disquettes
il y avait un petit peu il n'y a pas une
histoire de faux ramène aussi dans le
maxi d'air il ya des caractères donc en
fait ce sont 21 c'est l'impôt morphine
non ambiguë alors ça c'est important
d'entre eux finit aussi nos envies nuit
ça veut dire que ce sont des caractères
qu'on ne retrouve que chez les ornithos
qui dit d'aller les uns didier vidal
bazot il ya des caractères crânien comme
un foramen sur le prix maxi rd70
vraiment à l'extrémité intérieure à
hauteur du crâne on a dit à ce thème qui
semble être présent c'est à dire un
espace entre les dents antérieures et
postérieures au niveau de la limite
entre le prix maxi et maxi hier on a une
crêpe très prononcée au niveau du
maxillaire on à l'oscar et qui est cette
hausse qui certitudes avec la machine à
la mandibule qui sera incliné vers
l'arrière
on a un à six tables ou qui a toujours
été un caractère qui définissait les
dinosaures qui est ouvert par et ishi
santos kid
donc quand même et c'est pour ça que ça
a été publiée dans nature
ce serait quand même se construit par un
grand nombre de caractères mais il ya eu
la réponse de langueur et ses collègues
qui ont en fait constater que tous ces
caractères qui semble définir les zones
noires dites skikda c'est à dire les
théropodes et les antis siens et bien
serez présent si chez des enseignes des
dinosaures et chez et fort probablement
au primitif comme les
les erreurs au rite est d'accord du coup
on peut passer au à la réponse donc
inquiet ni combien presque neuf mois à
sortir donc cette réponse c'est un
article de langueur et de ses
collaborateurs
langueur qui nous vient du brésil je
crois que ça et parmi ses collaborateurs
il ya certains de mes collègues qui
nique blair mac qui travaille aussi sur
des os mais ce repos de mort bazot au
brésil donc est ce que tu peux nous
présenter un peu cet article ouais donc
dans la course de l'année à mango ou
comment expliquer de tout à l'heure ils
ont changé le codage de 2500 du
caractère présentée par marc un mental
et en faisant ça ils ont retrouvé son
appel la traditionnelle 1500 caractères
de 1500 m les cinq otages
oui moi 2515 le pas ce qu'il y'a que 415
un bouquin 2500 collages sur les 457
carte ils ont ils représentent à peu
près 10% je serai 10% après ils ont
gardé les 457 caractères originaux de
baronne bahreïn avait rajouté des
nouveaux marchés et ils ont rajouté
quelques cas qui nous basons oui c'est
exact en fait ça a été une des critiques
de longueur c'est que il ya deux
critiques très importantes qu'ils ont
formulées la première c'est que ils ont
dit que baronne navets et ses collègues
n'avait examiné que la moitié des taxes
sont des espèces de dinosaures et des
ans et des dinosaures qu'ils ont codé
dans leur matrice de données alors que
tous ces
tous ces auteurs ont eu la chance de
pouvoir examiner tesi l'entièreté des
espèces web comme ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez important quand quand quelqu'un
code un faux site
c'est que si on utilise un article avec
des images dudit fossiles
des fois les images cet été sans la
personne qui a fait les dessins étaient
plus focalisé sur quelques aspects de
l'os qui sont en train de décider et ne
va pas montré tous les détails
nécessaires pour avoir un codage correct
donc baronne étals avec le but où elle a
environ 50% des spécimens eux-mêmes et
le reste des cobayes s'était basé sur de
la littérature danse est l'objet de sa
collaboration avec paul baehr est
justement
ouais ouais tu as montré le matériel cas
le matériel tu lui avait montré dont
barbarisme en effet piscine on a
énormément de ce revêtement faisons donc
c'est surtout sur sa queue on a discuté
quand ils sont venus ils ont triché et
puis donc comme une pomme 10 et
christophe quand la réponse de la mer et
algues ils ont vu peut-être pas du tout
ils ont en tout cas des collaborateurs
qui ont vu concentre tous les fossiles
eux mêmes on peut on a tendance à croire
que leur courage à deux mondes plus
correct que ce bar mais bon après aussi
top
il ya aussi une réponse une réponse
faisons d'un autre
ouais mais quelles sont ces nouveaux
taxis qui ont inclus nouvelle ben il y
en a quelques-uns qui sont importants
donc par exemple ils ont décidé
d'inclure voilà c'est sous tutelle aux
russes qui étaient attirés au fort pas à
quelque chose qui serait l'ancêtre de
destine aux oreilles des en kilos d'or
pur à 6 dimon aux russes ça je connais
pas x à l'erp et ont donc ça c'est
certainement pas un dinosaure
eh bien rien restait alors faut quand
même reconnaître que par exemple le pire
y rester s'il y en avait une deuxième
ça a été publié je crois même cette
année donc on peut pas reprocher à
barran ne pas avoir un pc cet axe en
main parce que ça venait tout juste
d'être publié
en revanche il c'est vrai que moi ça va
être moi ce qui m'a étonné en fait j'ai
essayé d'être aussi un peu critique
parce que ils ont ils ont vraiment
éviter de d'inclure certains taxant qui
semble important par exemple dimon aux
russes qui est un terreau pote primitif
qui a été publiée en 2011
on s'étonne pourquoi et de n'a pas été
inclus dans leur matrice de 2 mais bon
c'est une fille dit qu'on peut faire à
tous les auteurs qui feront des années
de kalistick et c'est toujours très
compliqué d'inclure l'entièreté des
taxes aux décors et donc qu'est ce
qu'ils trouvent
qu'est ce qu'ils trouvent dans cette
révision quel est le résultat principal
bam est donc l'utilité retrouve l'arbre
traditionnel donc les théropodes et les
sauropodes serait plus proche de m
que les enfants ils retrouvent le
sourire ça m'est donc c'est ce qui est
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'ils le
lisent les trois armes les trois
possibilités d art gothique sur tout
aussi probable c'est quoi les trois
possibilités la première donc c'est la
traditionnelle c'est se risquer à titien
la deuxième celle qui a été proposée
donc pas par an c'est ornithos qui est
l'ida et donc ce qu'ils proposent ces
souris siens et ça a été critiqué parce
que les sauts risque bien d'en
comprendre les sauropodomorphes et les
erreurs
herrera zory des choses qu'ils auraient
dû en fait appeler tout simplement sort
pour la mort bref et la troisième on n'a
pas parlé c'est phyto dinosauriens et
fit dinosauriens peut-être en parler
kimi
c'est ce serait donc les théropodes d'un
côté qui sont des dinosaures carnivores
et tout le reste ce repos de maurs et en
it is tient des dinosaures exclusivement
les bigors qui serait retrouvée qui
s'était fait qui comprend qu'il se fait
compris dans le dans le même groupe
exceptés été proposée dans les années 80
par bancaire d'accord ça ça sent pas bon
la convergence tout ça mais ce serait
possible et c'est ça en fait langueur
dit que il eut en fait ce qui constate
c'est que en révisant tous ces
caractères malgré ça le clad et ce au
risque 1 n'est pas très robuste il
faudrait en fait quelques étapes pour
pour le changer 4 voilà quatre étapes
dont on parle d'état un amphi de lignes
fixes et c'est juste changé le codage
vocal de caractère
changement 4 codage quatre étapes moment
là tout l'homme cochon dans la partie
web dont les trois les trois arbres dont
on a parlé c'est le manque de caractère
voilà ton change en changeant quatre
caractères on peut s'effondrer le dessin
c'est ça en fait que ce que langueur et
ses coauteurs qu'on sait c'est que en
changeant quatre caractères il ne
retrouve plus les sorédiens et en
initiant cette dichotomie traditionnel
mais il retrouve les phyto qui nous ont
rien ils ne retrouveront en revanche pas
les ornithos candidat mais il note que
il faudrait quand même il faudrait pas
changé beaucoup de caractère pour
retrouver anita steed
c'est quelque chose qu'il aura acquis
qui a été donc une remarque qui a été
fait par par baron dans sa réponse c'est
que en effet certes ils ont peut-être
trouvé la dichotomie traditionnelle
souris scanner titien mais elle n'est
pas très bien supporté il faudrait très
peu de correcteurs caractère pour
retrouver les orientaux style et puis il
ya une 3e option qui serait les phyto
dit nous sommes donc en fait la
conclusion qu'on peut en tirer par
rapport à ces études là c'est que à
l'heure actuelle avec toutes les
matrices de données composée de teulé et
tous les dinosaures qui ont
qui ont été découverts jusqu'ici et bien
y'a pas vraiment une
une classification qui me prend pas qui
est plus probable que l'autre est donc
si ça pour la plus tard donc ça veut
dire que dans le futur tout ça peut
encore changer et bas-rhin et ses
coauteurs ont raison il est tout à fait
possible que cette dichotomie sont
risqués à et en et issia combes en
désuétude dans le futur c'est tout à
fait possible
on a peut-être un peu trop tendance à
prendre pour acquise la classification
sont risqués en et ischia alors que l'on
est on a un peu tendance à oublier qu'il
ya encore pas très longtemps
enfin ne pas retourner très loin en
arrière pour voir des articles qui
questionnait même l'amener au chili des
dinosaures
donc il ya des articles il ya notamment
bakker qui défend des sept possibilités
c'est que les dinosaures en existerait
même pas cet adversaire
les dinosaures n'aurait par un ancêtre
commun ils auraient juste différentes
branches de gros lézard qu'on appelle
d'un côté les théropodes de l'autre côté
les sauropodes est un troisième côté des
lesquels j'ai oublié mais en éthiciens
désormais dix cas est finalement qu on
les aurait un peu enfin ricciardo wayne
à la base les aurait réunis ensemble
parce qu'il avait trop de matériel et
que c'était voilà des gros lézard alors
on aimait dans le dans un groupe qu'on
appelle les gros lézard parce que
finalement si ce que dit nous on veut
dire actes terribles et les herbes
terriblement - et donc
à la base le groupe dinosaure a été
créée par des gens qui n'était justement
pas d'éclats liste parce que la claviste
hic n'existait même pas mais finalement
une fois que la quasi stick est apparue
même même le groupe même des dinosaures
a été remis en question finalement ce
n'est pas si étonnant de voir
aujourd'hui des gens qui remettent en
question qui remettent en question ce
risque et en été ce cas sur la base de
nouvelles analyses parce que finalement
c'est quelque chose qui est
continuellement qui veut être débattue
balaj j'aimerais quand même faire une
remarque suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec toi figure toi c'est que pack r si
je ne me trompe
il a proposé le fait que peut-être que
les dinosaures n'étaient pas moins de
politique donc aucun trois enfants de
classe c'est à dire que tous les
dinosaures partageraient points assez
trop directe mais si je ne me trompe
sans se baser sur la liste classique
jusqu'à l'heure c'est très possible que
certaines personnes n'est pas retrouvé
exactement le clac des dinosaures mais
encore une fois la très grande majorité
des analystes politiques qui ont été
faites ont toujours retrouver le club de
dinosaures donc dans l'analyse de varone
ils ont 5 1 six caractères ici pas
d'accord mais du coup ça exclut les
erreurs
gérard zaug rider ouest exact la
nouvelle azéri rasori des ne seraient
plus des dinosaures d'après d'après les
réponses bas il serait pas là donc c'est
aussi ça parce que ce qui est important
de pointé du doigt je pense c'est que on
dit les dinosaures
as tu dis les dinosaures c'est un groupe
monofil éthique mais au final ça dépend
si ce que tu inclus dedans absolument
que j'y vais tous les animaux ont un
ancêtre commun à un moment et tu peux
trouver un ancêtre commun des dinosaures
même si tu trouves même s'ils n'ont pas
s'être comme indirects finira par
trouver un ancêtre commun aux dinosaures
mais c'est juste voilà qu'est ce que tu
inclus comme descendant à cet ancêtre
commun dont des fois y'a les nra zo reid
à l'intérieur mais des fois ils n'y sont
pas mais il ya une définition des
dinosaures donc quand on parle d'un cas
de dinosaures c'est pas juste nommé
quelque chose qu'on en trouve dans une
analyse politique il ya une définition
la définition des dinosaures c'est
l'ancêtre commun aux mécanos zor et
autres icera top je crois peut-être au
stégosaure mitissien et donc c'est pour
ça que ce soit donc que le club des
dinosaures inclut les erreurs auraient
été ou pas ça c'est pas très grave
ouais mais si un jour une analyse
statistique retrouve le
megan aux ors du côté du coton les
oiseaux et il retrouve tricératops du
côté des mammifères ça voudrait dire que
le club des dinosaures c'est exactement
le même que le club d avenir absolument
sauf que ça n'arrivera jamais c'est par
définition on peut dire si c'est un défi
non mais non et donc voilà sur vas-y
d'années ici que le code des dinosaures
a toujours été retrouvé c'est dichotomie
son risque rien et anglo american et
essayer de retrouver la halle avantages
de cette définition ce qu'elle laisse
quand même la place à beaucoup de
flexibilité et du coup tu peut inclure
plat de groupe qui finalement n'était
pas considéré comme des dinosaures avant
mais qui du fait de cette définition
peuvent être englobée dans les
dinosaures
c'est exact mais ça va s'arrêter là bas
il faut aussi regarder donc dans
l'analyse les arabes sommet des quatre
taxes on est dans le groupe
donc ouais comparé au sort pozzoni
discale théropodes qu'ils on voit une
vingtaine 25 taxes ou mangou et c'est
quoi ces petites bêtes là au milieu qui
n'ont qui n'appartiennent à rien mais ça
c'est chine des eaux réussite à la
session d des théropodes la zone au
moment qu'ils sont retrouvés à
l'extérieur du clac et ornithos qu'ils
dînaient à part c'est très très bizarre
parce que ta voix quand même et a
vraiment une tronche de théropodes
toujours été retrouvés comme un terreau
peau de gazelle dans le tout les autres
analyse donc oui c'est encore une fois
c'est vrai que là ils ont un peu forcé
la lande nistos candidat du coup réalité
en réalité ce qu'ils ont retrouvé la
baronne dans leur réponse à la longueur
c'est que les gens me disent qu'ils sont
des théropodes nom de la salle ont lancé
leur à leurs résultats mais encore une
fois on doit ce rallye sur la définition
qu est-ce que les orgues et hostilités
les ordis peu ce qu'ils lisent c'est
donc tous les ancêtres ou alors tu dois
prendre deux expressions fais tu de ton
et mégalo szohr était de prendre la pose
et tricératops
si tu retrouves en fait les ancêtres
c'est l'ancêtre commun de ces deux
sp cela est tout tout tout leurs
descendants sa forme est la descendante
au speed et là tu le retrouve donc avec
talent a commencé à partir dans un débat
sur qu'est ce que doit être un classique
mais tu dois je dire finir tu voyais un
laminoir de la finition de ce que doit
être un clin d'oeil à la scène qui est
basé sur le noeud il ya celles qui est
basée sur les caractères troisième sais
pas mais je manque celle que c'est le
comble non mais non c'est l'ancêtre
commun c'est quoi déjà c'est notre based
n'obéissent enst mbx tu te remets que
deux jours based on baise dans donc
notre best c'est celle que tu as donné
tu prends deux espèces et c'est celle
qui est la dass et le clac c'est
d'ancêtre commun de ces deux espèces et
toutes les espèces par ex ce samedi les
mammifères sevré toutes les espèces qui
sont plus apparentes et à l'homme qu'à
n'importe quel qu'un autre eût avec par
exemple une grenouille je sais bien que
c'est pour ça mais bon on irait voir ça
c'est la nôtre boys band et donc à la
troisième qui est basée sur les
caractères voilà c'est ça c'est le 3e
c'est sur les caractères donc c'est par
exemple la définition des maliens forme
qui sont basés sur le changement de
l'articulation et la mandibule et ça on
n'a pas ça chez les dinosaures et ça n'a
jamais été définie comme je ne crois pas
qu'ils trichent non non non nous on
n'utilise que des stones des cmbs est
énorme et inutile jamais les caractères
oui en plus on utilise on n'utilise
jamais en fait à une caractères
anatomiques particulier pour définir
quelque chose c'est juste pour rappeler
à nos auditeurs qu'une classification
cet arbitraire et qu'au bout d'un moment
au bout d'un moment on peut aussi faire
un peu justement ce qu'on nous dit là
pour moi c'est parce que ce café baronne
sur le dernier article ça sent un peu la
tri feuillage c'est à dire que si on
considère que ces taxes sont là qui sont
à l'extérieur des hôpitaux ces 10 da
sont des théropodes en réalité désormais
dix cas ce sont des terreaux pourris
sauf que et le lait du groupe comme des
théropodes essart et du coup en est
aussi évident à neuneu ray apparaît pas
mais bref
mairie cc c'est pas fini comme histoire
s'est prononcé sur ses qualités c'est
qu'elle est bien sûr on va je crois que
donc jugé que c'est pas une bonne chose
d'augmenter les caractères je crois que
ça serait si cette future de thématiques
de données qui ont les plus en plus de
caractère et de plus en plus de taxes
ont déjà fui pour être mettre d'accord
sur les caractères et qu'ils ont déjà le
codage qu'ils ont déjà ce serait pas mal
d'ailleurs invité d'autres parce que
ouais donc pas fait dans la réponse à la
réponse par vannes et maintenant pas
d'accord avec la façon dont des régates
ont chanté le codage commenté pisa
suffisent à nos ruches pisano russie en
fait ils changent le cottage de pisogne
aux russes ils retrouvent pisano aux
russes en dehors des dinosaures et les
ornithologues qui seraient d'accord
ainsi hommage mais il ya donc un article
de baron et à l'original ensuite il ya
quelque chose que la red bull denise la
réponse dans lequel languir est en 2015
ont été changés 1504 2515 ont été
changés par mme illégales y ait eu des
changements suffisent à nous aux russes
exacte des barons étals en reprenant
cette analyse là est juste en changeant
le codage de pisa russe retrouve la
montre à dire pourquoi ils ont voulu le
changer ce codage banier contiennent un
bâton dans le codage de l'anr et à lille
ont causé des tripes comme par exemple à
la taille de la taille de la rumeur du
crâne le ratio entre le crâne fumure
d'identité et donc la rue
barre en métal c'est que le seul
spécimen mon âne pisano taurus n'a pas
de fémur ennakl un crâne complet comment
est ce qu est un métal ont réussi à côté
de toute l'espèce
à partir de là c'était si mais qui n'est
pas complet c'est ce qui est en
gestation peut-on faire confiance
et là il y aura une troisième équipe qui
va vérifier la longueur et ultimement
encore quelque chose
donc ce sera pour le mieux je pense
parce que bien sûr mais il devrait y en
avoir des loisirs sur cette nouvelle
analyse les plus on entendra dire
quelque chose de consensuel belle verte
c'est ça l'idée fait travailler ensemble
et si elle est d'accord sur le codage
qu'ils ont déjà
avant d'ajouter ce que la déjà en
comptant les équipes de barre en métal
et l'équipe de langue héritage ça fait
combien de personnes a déjà qui vient
shenzhen
ça fait déjà une quinzaine de personnes
dis moi ton tous ces gens sont d'accord
sur le fait qu' à théropodes en
hittistes et seront pas d'honorer la
maintenance et juste avant voilà des
dinosaures et qui enchaîneront à ses
enfants de travailler sur un truc pour
essayer de détruire et les tirs au pont
du périgord des tice tient finalement
été road au taurus c'était un terreau
potes depuis le début c'est pour ça
qu'il avait des petites dents pointues
ok donc oui mais je pense que c'était
très
très éclairante enfin voilà pour
quelqu'un comme moi qui qui donne des
cours de paléontologie et qui a mais qui
connaît pas si bien les dinosaures que
ça j'étais prêt et on va dire à changer
mon cours car ils hurlent hypothèse d un
doute hausser dida en tant qu hypothèse
a évidemment pour remplacer le paradigme
on va dire mais c'est vrai que du coup
d'avoir d'avoir justement de voir la
science en marche
finalement et le processus de
vérification parce que ma peau tendance
à critiquer le système de peer review en
disant qu'il ya des choses qui passent
au travers et tout ça mais le quai
review il s'arrête pas à la publication
de l'article le preview il ne commence
finalement qu'à la publication gratuite
ces voix là et c'est pour ça que quand
il ya tout ce système de publication
c'est que la publication rend les
données publiques et des données
publiques peuvent être re vérifier là
c'est exactement ce qui est en train de
se produire donc vous y êtes pour un
mental en fête en proposant un truc
aussi aussi étonnant aussi pour m'en
veux dire bref étonnant ça a poussé en
fait un nom de paléontologues à sa sauce
y entre pour re vérifier pour on peut
juste dire très rapidement aussi que la
matrix les résultats de parole il y
avait une hypothèse qui proposait où il
dit en fait que l'origine des dinosaures
seraient non plus dans l'hémisphère sud
et dans l'hémisphère nord et sa maman la
publication c'est une phrase et disais
oui c'est vrai que c'est en effet donc
c'était une critique de longueur
dix ans qu'ils n'ont pas fait de tan
aliz biogéographique c'est quoi mais en
effet c'était quand même pas l'objectif
de l'heure de leur publication à paroles
mais tout porte à croire points
jusqu'ici je suis athée qu'affectueux
les possibles qu'on a des dinosaures
oiseaux tout porte à croire que
l'origine dinosaur yen reste toujours
dans l'hémisphère sud qui va au congo
n'a plus tôt quand l'orage et 1 mais
est-ce que c'est pas un billet de
préservation parce que là le problème de
est-ce qu'on a des gisements qui est ce
qu'on a des gisements du même âge que
les gisements du coup d'argentine et
d'afrique du sud
on trouve les premiers dinosaures on en
attend du même âge en l'eurasia et qui
sont à coup sûr n'ont jamais livré de
dinosaures non non non donc on a bien on
a bien par exemple on a cet opus du
froid mais qui n'est pas considéré comme
un dinosaure mais qui vient décosse il
ya d'autres trucs décidé au rider qui
viennent bien de de l'hémisphère nord et
est saisie note des remarques de parents
disent en effet que le registre fossile
de la fin du trias sites en europe
et quand même très peu et et qui est des
nouvelles découvertes pourrait
complètement changer le fait
l'origine géographique des mesures ça
aussi ça peut encore changer avec des
côtes découvertes futures et ça je pense
que ça en fait c'était plus c'était pas
tant une réponse à l'article lui-même
qui comme l'a dit qui me dit une phrase
jetons avec ça ceci dit une phrase dans
un article de nature ça coûte cher
donc si l'on dit c'est qu'il le pensait
aimer c'est peut-être plus à une réponse
à aux aubois médiatique qui est après
parce que les médias par contre ils ont
fait exactement j'ai eu jean dinosaures
viennent en europe
les gosses je pense même qu'ils en aient
quoi j'ai vu des joueurs des titres
d'articles lui disait origines de
dinosaures en écosse et là là là je
pense que oui c'est exact il parle je
pense que je dis mais en fait tout ce
débat sur ornithos élida ou pas c'est
finalement à des bac et plus médiatique
que sa fille qu'enfin le débat
scientifique il existe puisque échanges
d'articles entre baronne et et langueur
mais c'est surtout un débat qu'il y ait
lieu sur la place publique avec
justement les médias qui font des gros
titres sur des affirmations qui demande
à être vérifiée ça c'est oui c'est la
conclusion générale de quasiment toutes
les vidéos
quand vous entendez un truc dans les
médias me fais toujours attention à la
précipiter pâtit mais finalement même
moi je me suis pris au jeu puisque
j'étais prêt à changer mon court et
finalement je suis prêt à leur vos
changements
voilà pas encore donc ornithos élida la
réponse est brillamment donné par kimi
ça c'était brillant passes étaient
présents c'est comme oreca pas encore
anna d'imaginer archives et qu'il 30
champions league
non
ok et d'un merci à tous les deux merci
qui merci christophe davy anticipait
cette vidéo donc j'espère et je dis à
très bientôt à tous nos auditeurs
ciao
[Musique]